what do you mean by digital modesty oh
yeah that's that's an idea I've been
playing with a lot recently which is
really just about where we've got to
with the exposure of everything on the
internet um this is something I found
myself thinking about a lot more and the
more the more I found myself writing in
public and speaking in public and really
sort of being present online whether
it's on Twitter or wherever which is is
is there anything that we shouldn't be
posting um and the more I think about
that the more the more I can clude that
yes there are absolutely things that we
shouldn't be posting or rather um if
there are things which if if we if we do
share them we should expect negative
consequences to follow from that I mean
I've and The more I've thought I've I've
derived a set I guess of basic
principles for what I won't post I won't
post selfies online I mean I I'll po my
face is all over the internet right but
in the context of a conversation you
know you and I are here you and I are
here not we're not here to talk about my
face I mean my face is just my face
we're here to we're here to exchange
ideas and to have a conversation but I
won't post I won't post selfies yeah I
can actually I remember the point where
I realized that you I shouldn't I didn't
want to post selfies was was just after
I I ran over the finish line of a
marathon a couple of years ago and i'
trained for it and I'd trained for it
and I'd trained for it and I'd worked so
hard at it and at that point I think I
had maybe 10,000 followers on Twitter
and I and I took a photo of myself
having crossed the Finish Line looking
like hell um completely exhausted and
out high as a kite on in orphin and I
nearly I nearly pressed send and then I
was like whoa don't do that do not do
that and I and I deleted it and I didn't
I I did not post the selfie of myself
having just crossed the Finish Line why
because I realized if I did like
probably 75% of the people who follow me
would say great well done
congratulations and I get lots of love
the other 25% would be the people who
hate follow because they they exist once
you get past a certain point you get you
have haters on the internet because like
people can find people can hate anything
you know that's just the law of the
internet people will find something
insane to hate even if it's just people
doing like middle-aged women doing
marathons um and and then and and it
would have there would have been one
mean comment which would have just
crushed me and it would have ruined my
day and I thought what's the easiest way
of not experiencing that one mean
comment it's just not just don't post
the picture but it's more than that it's
also that it it exposes something
intimate and personal which I realized
was just not something which was it
wasn't for all everybody else it was my
my my that that moment was for me and it
was for my for my family and for the
people who supported me it wasn't for
and and for the people who' who who'
who' supported me to fund raise it
wasn't for General consumption and and I
realized that actually there is a
boundary um and I've I've spent more
time online I've I've I've appeared in
public more since then and the more the
more I do it the more I've come to think
that actually we need you the the more
exposed you are potentially online the
more the more intentional you have to be
about thinking thinking thinking clearly
on where you draw the line like a
digital hijab yeah well I I wouldn't
that's that would be a problematic way
of putting it in public because I think
you there are
borrowing from other people from a faith
which I don't personally espouse um as
as a metaphor did modest do okay so no
selfies so no selfies no pictures of my
home no pictures of my child no pictures
of my husband no discussing my husband
my child or my home um except in the
most general terms um and and really no
no no discussing intimate Matters from
my social life and my my family life and
my home life um unless it's in in the
most general terms or with the consent
of anybody else involved because ultimat
like these are my these by virtue of
being relationships they're things which
don't just belong to me and because it
doesn't just belong to me I can't mind I
have no right to mind that for Content
justify for the non content creator
people why a degree of digital modesty
is also a good idea okay so the the more
I thought about digital modesty the more
I realized that what we're actually
talking about is is is is setting
boundaries on the culture of
transparency um and this is really
something which I think we've inherited
from the 1960s and the sort of hippie
utopianism and this idea that you know
if we all let it all hang out if we're
just open about everything if we all
just share and we're we're honest and
we're authentic then somehow
everything's going to be better and that
might have been true maybe that was true
to an extent before the internet because
there was a limit on what you could
share but now we have the internet we
could theoretically be documenting
literally every moment of our lives and
on those you know those people who've
tried documenting literally every aspect
of their lives online have generally
ended up in some pretty horrible places
I I can't remember the name of the guy
but there was there was a famous
there was a famous
subculture there was some guy online who
who who documented literally every
aspect of his life and he ended up
getting trolled and he he basically went
to some very dark places and ended up
you yeah in in in in profound kind of
yeah really Sinister kinds of audience
capture um it wasn't nicardo avocado was
it I he's a more recent case in point
actually I mean you know people who end
up sort of you know crying and breaking
up with with and and getting back
together again with his boyfriend whil
eating enormous plates of food basically
for internet clown you know there's
there's a sort of Race To The Bottom
aspect there but but more generally even
for people who are not uh professional
internet uh presence havs um the the
culture of the the culture of
transparency and the sort of tyranny of
transparency has negative effects I was
thinking about this like in the context
of dating I mean you you know
periodically you see these Tik toks
which which young men or women put out
where they're like oh you know I I've
just I I I pointed view you're on a date
and they're literally filming the date
um while they're on the date and then
they're criticizing the the the their
counterpart on the date while they're
actually doing it or they've gone to the
L to make a Tik Tok about how how their
date is going wrong while they're
actually having the date and I'm
thinking well if you if you never draw a
line and say if if you if you arrive in
a sort of potentially intimate situation
you've always got that imagined audience
in your head which is potentially
everybody on the internet how are you
ever supposed to create a shared
intimacy with anybody and I think so
it's like transparency it's not just the
enemy of Desire transparency is the
enemy of intimacy it's the enemy of
relationships and you if if there's
nothing if there's no Gap at all between
what you'd say on Maine and what you'd
say in private there there intimacy is
just meaningless it's not a thing one of
my friends who I came up doing Club
promo with he was in Southampton and I
was in Newcastle running the same event
Carnage which was an event where you
bought a t-shirt as your ticket and
there was tasks on the back like uh
pulled a pig got off with three randoms
uh swapped shoes with somebody etc etc
right very sort of mid naughties Larry
British rinking culture stuff um and I
was asking him where he thought that the
Larry culture which although maybe not
exactly like emotionally healthy is a
kind of uh liberated Lous uh which kind
of speaks of a degree of transparency
and honesty and Truth like I'm just
going to do what I want right I'm not
going to perform uh and where that had
gone where like the Larry like you know
pulled randoms in a club type thing cuz
that's not what happens we see doesn't
happen anymore no and he said it's
because of this sort of imaginary
audience starzy surveillance state run
by glial volunteers which is everybody
with a phone in their pocket yeah
exactly that you know there's no there's
no you can't do pranks you can't you
can't have a a crazy night out with your
friends anymore I mean we we threw some
completely boners parties when I was
when I was you late teens early 20s I
remember the the absence and laughing
gas party which I can only remember kind
of in in bursts and that there was a
magical evening which are you
Unforgettable and also unremember um but
there's absolutely no way that could
have happened any of it um if if if
camera phones had been a thing at the
time and I'm thinking you know there are
there are a huge number of benefits that
come there there are new kinds of
communication the new forms of
relationship I mean you and I wouldn't
be sitting here talking to one another
if it wasn't for this phenomenal
technology that we have that brings
people together in some ways but if we
if we're not able and willing to set
boundaries um on what we will and won't
share then it it it will eventually
scoop out everything that's inside us
and leave us no scope for intimacy or
interpersonal connection at all
ultimately everything becomes performant
everything's content so I had a
conversation with George my friend
earlier on and we were saying I had an
aversion to taking photos for a while
because given
my love Island alumnist status I had
seen a lot of people who did photos and
I Associated every time you take a photo
of yourself or what you're doing or
whatever that is you Shilling yourself
for content on the internet but that's
not true people took photos way longer
before social media existed so I had
Associated the only reason for taking a
photo is to post it online therefore I
won't take a photo because I don't want
to be one of those wanky L violent
people that post all of their life
online but that caused me to not post my
life online which I wasn't going to do
anyway but also not take any photos of
the fun stuff that I was doing so I've
got these huge dirs of of my life where
I don't have photos of me and my friends
doing stuff I went for lunch with
Douglas the other day I wanted to C like
I was like I want to remember this I
want to remember the pink shirt that he
was wearing And the fact I had Crocs on
and like you know just like stuff I'm
like okay let's take a photo but I have
to get over my own fear that I'm doing
it for Content even though I know I'm
not going to post it it's like a got
like like [__] projecting myself into
the future that I'm not a part of but is
the stuff that you would just
categorically never
photograph no no I would I would it
would be like times with friends you
like I'm on a hike with some friends or
whatever but I'm in nature and I feel
like I'm supposed to be like I'm
primitive man here and I shouldn't have
my phone out because it feels gush
somehow to do it or whatever you know
what I mean it's like here I am at the
top of the mountain but it's not it's
here I am with my friend that I've just
taken a hike with and I really want to
remember this or maybe I'll frame it and
put it on my wall at some point or
something like that seems like all of
that stuff's good idea that's a good use
of Technology up until the point at
which you everything becomes an only
fans for yourself I don't know I'm
possibly slightly more radical than that
in the sense that well I mean I mean I
think about when I'm I I run a lot
um so I'll I'll run red
flag you you you lift I run it's just
you know
if um so so I run a lot and and one of
the reasons I run is because I can't do
that while simultaneously scrolling like
I I the the reason you can LIF actually
you can do it in between sets the reason
the reason I obsess about all of this
stuff is because UL like I'm I'm so so
hardwired to to the the the rage machine
like I'm so plugged into the internet
which is why I I find myself kind of
wrestling with the outer limits of it at
all and one of the reasons I run and one
of the reasons I I treat that as
absolutely sacran space in my life is
because it's physically impossible to do
that while simultaneously scrolling and
I have a an absolutely cast IR rule for
myself that it doesn't matter how
beautiful the scene doesn't matter how
gorgeous the sunrise when I've gone for
like a 2-hour Dawn run and I'm out in
the middle of nowhere I will not stop
and photograph it I will not I will not
stop and record that because I don't
want to allow space for that imaginary
audience but see there again there's no
reason I understand why you do that I
think that's a noble like set of rules
to set for
yourself the reason that that has
happened is because of the social media
side not because of the photo side let's
say that you had a beautiful photo album
of all of the beautiful sunsets that
you'd ever seen it is again this sort of
crossing over of the barrier of not just
this is for me but that there is
something inbuilt into technology that
kind of like infect it gets into me and
if I open my phone oh my God what if I
see a [__] notification from Twitter
and then I'm sucked into a scroll hole
of my entire run is is ruined and stuff
like that I say it's a shame that
something which can be you know my
videographers got this like real special
sort of pointand Click camera that is
very low friction and he bought it
specifically even though he had all of
the kit in the world but he bought this
very specific camera which is just point
and shoot and all it does is that and he
bought that to remove the friction and
remove the performative nature of this
so I just think it's it's an interesting
blend but we we were talking before
about how um
people who put a lot of themselves
online they can have unforeseen
repercussions I guess if a lot of people
are clustering together over their
political opinions and if you even
pseudonymously post hardcore political
opinions on the internet eventually the
person that you're potentially looking
to date is is presumably going to get
exposed to whatever it is that you do
online and if you are a hardcore if
you're [__] Bronze Age pervert or
something it's like oh all right like
and now I have this entire other side of
you needs to be folded into our dating
pool and I learned from Scott Galloway
in 1960 one in 25 parents had concerns
about their child marrying someone from
the opposite political party by 2018
almost half of democrat parents and a
third of Republican parents had such
concerns and a third of each party sees
the other party as an enemy so given
this sort of clustering around political
opinions more than many other things and
a lot of people doing the pseudonymous
anonymous [__] posting online thing you
are potenti creating a future in which
your uh entire mating pool has been
restricted by opinions that you had 6
months ago and you've got the choice
between either lying to somebody about
your [__] posting online thing or trying
to somehow fold that into a conversation
that they can be accepting of I'm not
even sure how you how you resolve that I
mean I I'm fortunate I'm immensely
blessed in that my husband and I met
some time ago and this was just this has
just never really been you know before
before even really before you were an
opinion sprayer before I was a
professional op op h a long time before
I was a professional opinion H um and
really long before political
polarization was anywhere near its
current level of completely about chit
crazy so I mean it was it was completely
academic and and the honestly honestly
Chris the the advice I give to anybody
anybody who's single and extremely
online is date somebody who's just not
very online you know you can only have
one very online person in a relationship
you know except in the most unusual
circumstances because and and
anecdotally from younger friends I know
who are also opinion havs whether
anonymously or uh or or on the under
their own faces um anecdotally it's a
real problem because well I mean you
know quot one one one right-winger non
who I chat to periodically who should
remain nameless um told me that I mean
I'm I'm paraphrasing a little bit but
but but essentially um he he he has he
has a real problem because if he like he
says if your choices your choices
between an ego Wing e girl and they're
generally un like a little they can be
on the unstable side um or somebody who
doesn't know anything about your
opinions in which case how on Earth are
you going to explain what you do what
you spend all day doing online and
furthermore what what's going to happen
when she finds out about your opinions
on the internet you know it's not going
to be great like it's a real problem so
like how how how are you supposed to
form any kind of a any any kind of a
genuine mutually satisfying relationship
under those circumstances I don't know
the answer I mean I I suppose I come
back again to to digital modesty and the
idea that we have to reserve some some
space for intimacy which is protected
from from the imaginary audience that we
have on the internet and actually I
think in some ways what the anons do is
is wise in that sense because by virtue
of being a non they've already drawn a
very clear boundary you know they said
there are but but you know if you want
to stay if you're a non and you want to
stay a non um you there are there
there's a whole sede of stuff that you
just can't share you can't really post
anything about where you are or what you
do for a living or you know or or
anything that's too close to what what
your what Your day-to-day activity is
and so and so that that creates just by
it's a very a very blanket way of
setting some boundaries on what you're
willing to share but for the rest of us
uh it's it's a real challenge knowing
knowing where to draw those lines and
where and where to protect your where
where to protect what's just yours and
what belongs to you and the people you
love Yeah Douglas taught me a couple of
years ago uh keep your private life
private Y and um I think you know one of
the things that people can see is that
relationships and makeups and breakups
and the vicissitudes of your personal
life can be a very effective wedge to
begin Levering uh to be able to create a
an audience right it's the same as it's
the same as every person who decides to
call out some other internet commentator
and have an argument with them that's a
very effective way to Garner eyeballs
yeah attention and eyeball
but at what cost what does it say about
you what sorts of conversations does it
the machine always wants more yeah
correct doesn't doesn't matter what how
much you feed at the machine always want
if you think that having a relationship
is hard try having a relationship with a
couple of million people who are also
invested in the outcomes of your
relationship you know every so often I
see I see a nons with a bit of a
platform you know report that it it
somehow it's somehow comes out that the
two two people who have a bit of a
platform of having a relationship with
one another and all of a sudden
everybody cares and everybody want and
I'm like why am I even invested in this
I have no idea who these people are but
it's I I don't know maybe it's just a
byproduct of being otherwise relatively
atomized and feel like basic human need
to sort of feel like you have a wider
Community I wonder if a little bit of it
is kind of like um who wins in a fight
between Batman and Superman like who
gets into a relationship please say more
I don't know what you mean well that
like you've got two people both of whom
you know individually and they are now
in a relationship together and you go oh
what happens if these Two Worlds Collide
you know Cooper got engaged the other
day and she announced on the internet
that it was like the back of her
fiance's head maybe the side of his arm
and his shoe or something and it's like
this is the first and last time that the
internet's going to see a part of like
my husband's body he's fiance's body
he's not interested in being famous and
I really like him for that and that's
what you've got there it's like a
one-sided internet relationship uh and
she did a little bit of time talking
about it and now she's just going to
move on but yeah you you've got to be
careful and again to kind of sing the
song for the people who don't have a a
following or a desire to monetizer or
any of the other things it is a genie
that does not go back in the Box
toothpaste does not go back in the tube
because once there are photos of things
that you have on the internet the place
that you live the kids that you have
like little stuff like you know if you
take a photo of your kid in the school
uniform on their first day of school
guess what that school uniform
identifies which [__] school they go
to so yeah very very very interesting
talking about this I found a study that
I think is is kind of associated a
survey was sent out breaking down
whether participants of different
political ideologies would refuse to
date a current only fans worker and an
only fans subscriber percentages of
participants who would not date a
current only fans worker left leaning 43
moderate 63 right leaning
84 percentages of women who would not
date a current only fan subscriber left
leaning 70 moderate 78 right 84 so right
is 84 for both but there are way more
left leaning people who would date an
only fans's worker than would date an
only fans subscriber and I think that
that says kind of quite a lot about some
of the signaling that people on the left
are looking to do at the moment that
like sex work is real work and we you
know you can like monetize yourself as
you wish but there is still an inherent
ick from women to the men who are a part
of that ecosystem
I I would be curious to to hear like
what the what the methodology was and
whether there was any effort to control
for preference falsification how up well
I mean when you think about when when
you think about what Orthodoxy is on the
left um around you know sex work is work
and yada yada yada um I'd be willing to
bet that there would be a subset of
people who asked you know would you be
willing to date and only fans worker
would lie and even if they weren't
actually even if actually honestly if
you ask them in the pub privately off
the Record they they'd be like yeah know
that gives me the ick um if if you ask
them in that sort of a context they
would give they would give the morally
approved answer for for their political
tribe which is oh yeah that's fine sex
work is work or I I don't know maybe
some of them genuinely don't care but I
I'm willing to bet that it's a higher
proportion actually of of of men on on
both sides of the political Spectrum who
who don't actually find that appealing
what do you learn about the wouldn't
date a current only fan subscriber thing
okay so so the difference between
well like a guy who's addicted to porn
is BAS is fundamentally low low status
you know and I think it's it's polit
it's moral it's considered morally
acceptable across the entire political
Spectrum to dunk on to to to dunk on
lonely like masturbatory horn dogs
that's like no nobody nobody cares about
them you know that that's that's you
know incels are low status yeah per and
the born addicts yeah the the simps the
simps the perverts and the and the porn
sick like losers like no nobody cares
about them everyone's happy to to dunk
on them so there's less of less of op
pression to preference falsification
whereas whereas women women in the sex
industry have a much big much heftier
architecture of sort of moral hectoring
around them at least on the left so so
that would be that would be my read on
what's going on there preference
falsification what did you learn after
the release of the Barbie movie did you
reflect on sort of what that did
culturally did it do anything culturally
I think there was an awful lot of
conversations around what true feminist
power feminist power means and whether
or not there is still this sort of
rampant patriarchy that is kind of
keeping women down and so on and so
forth and then there was the right-wing
reaction and there was the left wing
leftwing re reaction to the right-wing
reaction and all the rest of it so I I
thought it was interesting you know if
anything that Ben Shapiro needs to do a
45 minute video about like after he's
watched dressed as Ken I thought was an
interesting uh yeah I thought it was an
interesting opportunity my favorite read
on the Barbie movie was was that that it
was a straightforwardly reactionary text
and that it wasan might and that it was
it was arguing fundamentally against
feminism and arguing fundamentally for
women as the for for for the embodied
differences between men and women and
that that there was there was nothing
there was nothing Progressive or
feminist about it at all how so how what
would you say to the people who are like
how could you say this there was it
obviously was pushing back against men
and men were on the receiving end of all
of the jokes and they laughed at them
and all the rest of the things
but they but pregnant Barbie was
expelled from the Barbie verse I mean
there's no darker commentary on the on
the on the boundaries of liberal
feminism I mean this is this is what I
spend my entire professional career
harping on about Chris is the is the
fact that liberal feminism has a mother-
shaped blind spot and it's right there
in the film it's it's as though it's as
though the I mean even if it was meant
as a liberal feminist text it's a
liberal feminist text that's telling on
itself in a in a sort of compulsive
verbal diarrhea way and and and this is
the this is the reactionary read of of
the Barbie movie I mean you know from I
suppose you could say that it's it's in
the N like a good piece of art is never
is never a straightforward poit piece of
political propaganda you know it doesn't
work like good stories are never are
never straightforward moral lectures you
know good stories always always contain
the the the the other perspective and
good stories are always just more
complicated than that but I mean even if
even if it was intended as a piece of of
feminist propaganda it told on itself in
some powerful ways including by that
detail of expelling pregnant Barbie from
the Barbie verse in other news this
episode is brought to you by element
element is a tasty electrolyte drink mix
with everything that you need and
nothing that you don't it's a healthy
alternative to sugary electrolyte drinks
and it is the best way that I have
started my morning every single day for
over three years now it contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium with no
sugar no coloring no artificial
ingredients or any other junk your
adenosine system that caffeine acts on
isn't active for the first 90 minutes of
the day but your adrenal system is and
salt acts on your adrenal system so if
you want to be more awake want to
regulate your appetite curb cravings and
have better brain health this is the way
to start your day head to drink LM
nt.com modern wisdom to get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box plus there is a nobs no
questions asked refund policy so you can
buy it 100% risk-free that's drink LM
nt.com
SL modern wisdom I was talking to Louise
about the unobvious ways in which our
culture is anti-am I didn't get round to
actually finding out I just hopped on
myself um what would you say some of
the ways that people might not realize
that culture could be anti- family well
I I can give you a very straightforward
anecdote so I don't live in London I
live I live out in the boonies um uh I
have I've traveled into London with a
toddler in a push chair um and you know
occasionally somebody will help you up
and down the steps on the tube with your
push chair sometimes people do something
some some sometimes people don't um but
like nobody will really give you the
time of day nobody looks at your kid um
can't really I'm not sure that I could
explain why I've also traveled into
London with a dog um everybody wants to
talk to your
dog right I mean is it not just that
dogs are better than humans across the
board like you your your daughter is
beautiful and and very lovely but it's
impossible to be better than a dog I
think that's the way it works you you
only say that cuz you don't have kids
true fair enough look here's the thing
that I I've also realized dog walks past
you you're everybody a dog is kind of
like it's the world's pet it's not your
pet because you are allowed to go over
and tap it on the head and what's your
name and blah blah blah blah blah if
someone presumably it might be nicer if
more people acknowledge your daughter as
she walked by but if they started coming
over and patting her on the head and in
other count that happens I mean you
maybe not the feeding Treats but in
other countries like people respond to a
to a random child completely differently
you get warm looks you get interactions
from strangers it's only in Britain that
people are like oh I must not look at
your child and I don't I don't know that
I I don't fully understand the
psychology behind not looking at
somebody else's child or not wanting to
even acknowledge that there's a little
person in thecity there's something very
distinctive about it do you wonder if
it's like the non radar thing that
people are so concerned of being seen as
like some latent sexual predator there
is for men that's definitely a factor
and I I know that because i' I've spoken
about it with with male friends and
peers who you know who who confirm to me
that they they'll they'll be very
cautious about interacting with with
mothers and children in in in a public
setting um because they're terrified of
being labeled in that way and I think
there's something really toxic about
that and something well I've found I
think I've told you this that over the
last few years my paternal Instinct has
started to kick in and children have
gone from being super annoying and lame
to like kind of cute
so but I I see a child now like let's
say it's like some little girls being
walked Along by her mother or father or
whatever in the park near where I live
and I'm like oh like I grin at whoever
the over the top go over the top I'm
like I'm going this way
okay um and I'm like this is huge yeah
well it's enough water you're high
you're highly performance athlete um and
I like have a grin at the child as they
walk past and I'm thinking oh [__]
hell I'm the strange man I'm like the
the 30s year old man with a pocket full
of we's Originals precisely correct it's
really dark it's really dark it's really
dark and and I want I mean you the the
the total number of noning today is no
no no higher actually than it was 50 20
30 50 years ago if anything so but but
the the level of panic is so much
greater right so the anti-
child accepting and pleasantry culture
isn't helping to reduce the noning rate
it's just making life for
it's just making life Lon mother and
kids like kind of more lame I mean it's
very it's it's difficult I I don't know
that I would be I i' I'd be cautious
about drawing clear causal lines between
those things and and whether whether the
the stranger danger and all of that
Panic is is a cause or an effect I I'd
be hesitant to speculate without a bit
more data but
um none of it none of it helps you to
feel any more part of a community when
you're existing in public with a child
let alone multiple children right yeah
does it feel alienating a little
bit well I mean it's it's it's
particularly palpable when you've got
very small children because I mean when
before before once your kid is in school
you're sort of in this in in in a you're
kind of part of an ecosystem at that
point you know you you're you're part of
the of the school mom's WhatsApp group
and you're part of you're part of a
community and you know there are events
you go to and you see the same kids
around at um brownies or whatever um and
so so after you you sort of start to fit
in with with a fabric of other people
and you and you do realize that actually
some I mean if you live in a small town
as I do at least you know that if if
you're if you're fortunate enough to
live somewhere like that then that
something of that fabric is still there
even if you do have to go looking for it
a little bit um but but when when you
when you're a very new mom particularly
when it's your first or in my case my
only um it's it feels like you've just
you've just fallen off the edge of the
world into somewhere completely
different and you know old old women
will smile at you on the street but
pretty much pretty much nobody you it's
very hard to establish where you fit at
all apart from that there's a lot you
know going back to kind of I guess
Barbie's cultural commentary uh there's
a lot of talk about the crisis of
masculinity at the moment if I was to
make a prediction for the next sort of 5
to 10 years I think that I would project
out that there will be a big crisis of
femininity coming down the pike at least
a little bit I I think that it it it it
can't be the case that women continue to
grow up because there is a dir of good
male role models but the female role
models are no better the only difference
is that they're allowed to be on TV more
that they get more R time and that when
women have problems there is a little
bit more mainstream sympathy I think
that's probably true I mean I suppose I
would frame it very slightly differently
um like the the problem as I see it
isn't it's not it's not necessarily just
a crisis of masculinity or a crisis of
femininity it's a total crisis of
embodied humanness which hits the Sexes
differently um and which is Downstream
of having developed a culture in which
almost nothing about our physical bodies
makes very much difference at all um at
least if you if you live in if you do a
knowledge based if your if your
occupation is in the world of
information I mean if you I mean if
you're an oil rig worker obviously like
your physical Body Matters a lot you
know to an if you do something physical
um but those those that that as a
proportion of the economy has been
shrinking and shrinking and shrieking
with with indust de Industrial first
first with the the the the de rural
depopulation as agriculture
industrialized and then with the
industrial re with with de industrial
deindustrialization is the second tier
of that you know the number of people
who do manual work has been shrinking
with every generation and and the number
of people who do who who work in the
world of information has been growing
and I mean if you work in the world of
information it doesn't matter what shape
your body is gender neutral occupation
yeah exactly they're all gender neutral
occupations in theory any of us could be
driving a spreadsheet doesn't matter you
know and driving a spreadsheet and
arguably I mean the same the same goes
arguably to a great extent for the for
the being a professional opinion however
it doesn't matter what sex you are yeah
the keyboard wielders can be the same
sex it it doesn't matter and and and
there's a real there's a concrete
question which face confronts all of us
in that context which is to what extent
does do our bodies even matter and I
think really this is what the gender
ideologues are pushing at from the
opposite direction you that they're
they're making a very strong statement
that you know what shape my body is
doesn't matter so much so in fact that
I'm entitled to remodel mine as I see
fit and and then and and making building
a whole
political platform on the basis of that
premise and and else but but everybody
is confronted with the same qu even
people who are not signed up to the
whole sort of meet Lego worldview
everyone's confronted with the same
question if if I'm driving a spreadsheet
or being a professional opinion H like
what what difference does it even matter
you know who cares who cares what shape
my body is you know is is masculinity or
you know what does it mean to be a man
or to be a woman when when we're all
just you know disembodied heads on the
internet I I don't know the answer to
that but I grapple with it every day
well it's definitely
something I think that people grapple
with and ultimately you know given that
work is maybe one of the most important
things that you do that might contribute
but there will be times where your
biology and your
predisposition smash up against your
nature and the experiences that you have
in life I completely agree and I think
this is this is what we this is what it
would benefit all of us to to be more to
be talking more about and to be leaning
more into and I mean sometimes it you I
see people making early attempts at that
or sort of trying to trying to find ways
into that and you get these sort of
ridiculous kind of Trad subcultures for
example who are trying to find ways to
be men and women in a sort of post-human
age which is really kind of what we're
talking about here you and and it kind
of doesn't work and it's kind of cringe
and often I mean what would be an
example well I mean okay so backing up a
bit so there was a there was a real like
among the alt-right in particular this
is something which I've been reading
into a bit recently um among the
altright you know in between sort of
2016 and maybe 2020 there was a real the
there was a real boom in influences of
both sexists but actually quite a lot of
young women um who were who were calling
for you know pushing back against the
kind of modern degeneracy and saying you
know we should all we should all
re-embrace traditional gender roles and
we should have more all traditional
setup relationships and that we could
fight back against the collapse of
everything in that way um as it turned
out a lot of those a lot of the women
who actually tried doing that um just
absolutely hated it or or Le the
relationships were really messed up and
it turned you know a lot of the
relationships were abused abive and
there are women who are coming out of
that now having survived an an alt-right
attempt at a Trad relationship who are
just massively beaten up and traumatized
by the experience and who are now the
sort of unhinged kind of subset of uh
like post altright radical feminists
what was their what was their experience
of the relationship well I mean I
I if you if if you want an example of
somebody who went who went all the way
through one one variant of this you
should look up Lauren Southern's story
okay I mean you know without wanting to
make any comment on her opinions or her
political trajectory but I mean she she
went through something along these lines
and ended up living in a trailer park
with a with a toddler um you know having
having married somebody who was possibly
a Fed it was it was all yeah right I
mean it was a great absolutely crazy Arc
and you know having having leaned all
the way into being a kind of alt-right
you know Trad anti-feminist influencer
she yeah she ended up as a single mother
living in a trailer park and is now I I
don't know what she's doing now but yeah
I mean there there are a great many
people who did who sincerely tried to
kind of resynthesize something like the
old the old way of men and women
interacting and have found that it just
just blew up underneath them and I don't
know for all I know there were there are
relationships who formed and the which
are still flourishing but there were a
lot there were a lot of others that went
extremely wrong what is it that's
blowing it up I don't know I I honestly
I think like trying to trying to reverse
engineer a set of a set of soci sex
differences without the material
underpinnings which created those sex
differen those different sex social
norms is just it's a it's a Fool's
errand honestly what like can you get
specific okay like vague but specific uh
I I'll have to come at this from the
other direction um so so one of the
themes one of the themes in I've written
about in feminism against progress is
the the th those ways in which like men
and women have both always worked you
know at least up until the beginning of
the industrial year men and women always
worked but both sexes did and they did
so complimentarily ivanich writes
beautifully about this in gender I
strongly recommend as a book if you're
interested in in the the the Deep
history of of the relations between the
Sexes and he writes he writes about how
in premodern premodern agrarian largely
agrarian life you know men's work and
women's work were always always
different and and what constitutes men's
work or women's work will vary depending
on the context um but they're always
different and they're always defined in
relation to one another and they're
always Ambiguously complimentary um and
he describes it as like the relationship
between your right hand and your left
hand they always know where they are in
relation to us another and they're
they're not the same but they but they
mirror one another and they work
together and and that's and the nature
of men's work and women's work in a
harvesting and processing for exactly
exactly and there are even down to the
language used down to the kind of the
social spaces occupied even even down to
the the kinds of tools which are
considered acceptable for one sex to use
rather than the other and the you know
he describes Villages where it would be
considered deeply humiliating for a man
to touch the tools that would be
normally used by a woman it was just
completely rolling pin exactly you know
it would be utterly utterly Unthinkable
get off my P and mortar for for one sex
to touch the tools which are reserved
for the
other and and so this is and and that
that emerges out of a material context
in which everybody needs to work in
order for survival to in order in order
for for life to happen um and and and
what happened you know as as we as the
world is industrialized and we've
entered I mean what what he what he
calls the the transition from vernacular
gender which is The Ambiguously
complimentary world of men's work and
women's work into the world the world of
economic sex which is which he he
describes he describes as more sexist
than than the world of vernacular gender
because although although life is less
gendered in practice um by pretending
that everything is unisex you end up
with women being structurally
disadvantaged because tacitly the
default becomes the masculine one and
this is the world this is what Caroline
Creo Perez talks about when she in the
great another great book invisible women
where she writes about how um how so
much of the built environment and the
physical environment and tools and and
norms and default medical defaults and
you know Crash Test Dummies and you know
all kind you know surgical instruments
and so on are all are all constructed
for a male default and and the and the
women's distinct physiology and which is
subtly different and some in in some
biomedical contexts extremely different
is just is just quietly rendered
invisible and and this is this is really
what Lich is talking about when he talks
about the the the more sexist nature of
economic sex because it by by refusing
by by pretending that men and women are
interchangeable it renders it
effectively renders women you've got a
male default you interestingly I guess
when you move across into uh me the
world of mental health you're looking at
a female default you know uh I think
that's very true inter just bringing
this back to the question of why why
trying to reverse engineer um ambiguous
complimentarity in in the world of
economic sex now that we've got those
that now we've got that vocabulary in
place I I can maybe explain what I mean
when I say it's a bit of a Fool's erand
because I mean because in a sense you
know you can't like you can't put the
toothpaste back in the tube um you can't
we can't go back to to the world to the
world before modernity we're stuck with
it now um we're stuck with this world in
which everybody's pretending that men
and women are interchangeable and and to
a significant extent in the world of
bits and bites we kind of are and and
under those circumstances to say well
we're just going to decree that we're
going to have a premodern division of
sex labor within our private at home um
I mean it's a it can work like for some
for some people it kind of does but I
think you just need to be a little bit
less doctrinaire about it and anybody
who sets out to be rigidly ideological
about it is setting themselves up for a
toxic Dynamic and potentially domestic
abuse yeah the I mean in practice if you
ask most married heterosexual married
couples um you they will they'll if
pretty much any of them will tell you
that there are jobs that he does and the
job there are jobs that she does CU
that's just how it falls out and because
you both prefer it that way I mean I can
I could give you what's that were it not
for digital modesty I could give you
examples from my own family but I'm not
going to um there's a it's like the
specialization of Labor almost right but
domestic specialization of labor but
there are I mean there are instances in
my own family where the the division of
labor is counterintuitive if you were if
you were coming at it from a rigid
doctrinaire point of view it wouldn't it
wouldn't be the the way it is but but it
it works that way because we both like
it that way so moving forward in that
case the we should return to a tradcon
history in the future is that that's
just a a dead end as far as you're
concerned well I I I think we need to be
we just need to be a bit more attentive
to where we are and I think we can we
can afford to be a little bit more
respectful of indiv the the Dynamics
within individual couples I mean it's it
it's generally like there are patterns
which emerge you know in any in any
given heterosexual couple you know
that's been together long term they be
there'll be things which are more
typical of the male partner and things
which are more typical of the female
partner and I and that's fine you know
we shouldn't be trying to fight against
those stereotypes if if they're what
works for people but I but but I don't
see much point in imposing imposing kind
of you should be doing this or you
shouldn't be doing that you know because
because ultimately you people guidelines
people do need guidelines but people you
know people work people people can
figure out what works best for them I
mean here's here's one example
um so talking in very general terms I
mean I've made the argument that the
problem with Trad wives as such is that
they're just not Trad enough um in the
sense that the what they're harking back
to is a sort of mid mid 20th century
template which was actually only true
for a very small subset of the middle
class and which is distinct in itself
distinctively modern because in in
premodern times all women worked pretty
apart from the the very very richest
right so you're saying so the idea send
it further back agrarian grab your pesel
and mortar and hoe and get working in so
so the question I want to ask is what
what does a 21st century version of the
premodern in productive household look
like you know the the house where the
basic economic unit is your household
and so you've agreed you're all in it
together you're there for the long term
you know everything that you do you do
for the team um and then it's then it's
just a matter of agreeing of of of
figuring out how how how to get the best
out of everybody and I and like I can't
I'm not interested in legislating for
any given couple what that looks like um
and then in in a modern context where
most of us work in the world of in the
world of bits and bites anyway I don't
know I can't I can't I can't make that
determination for you yeah um but but
you but there will be a way you know
when you when you form your household
and you and you and you make your
decision about how you can get the best
out of your productive household
there'll be there'll be a there'll be a
pattern and I think there's there's no
shame in in accepting that sometimes
that can fit into a more traditional
mold what was that Insight that you had
about women needing to develop Vel a
strategy for not having it
all well I guess that's just a variation
on talking about productive households
because I mean when again in feminism
against progress the the the analogy
I've given is weaving which I think is
it's a very it's a very powerful
illustration of what happen to to
women's work at the beginning of the
Industrial Revolution in that for for
some sort of 10 20 30,000 years prior to
the Industrial Revolution weaving was
always women's work and there are very
there are solid practical reasons for
that um you can weaving is something I
mean the a household needs textiles
right you know you don't have textile
factories somebody needs to make
textiles you know you need them for
clothes and you need them for all sorts
of different things so so somebody's got
to do the weaving um and and somebody's
also got to look after the kids happily
weaving and looking after kids are
fairly compatible because you can raise
a loom off the floor um you can you can
put down you can put down your
repetitive you can do it whilst keeping
an eye on you know toddlers or small
people running around and it's
interruptible and it's social so so it's
it's ideal work to be to be getting on
with while you've also got small
children underfoot and so for for
Millennia Millennia after Millennia
weaving has been women's work and but
but weaving was also one of the first
Industries to move out of the home um
into factories and at that point uh at
that point it was very it was much more
difficult for it to continue to be
women's work and you know those those
workingclass women who went to work in
the textile mills had real dilemmas on
their hands because I mean what do you
meant to do with your breastfed baby you
know and there was there was there were
horror stories about you know how how
women tried tried their best to cope
with that you know babies drugged with
opium or you know left to starve or you
know you know left in the inadequate
care of yeah awful stuff and then and
then there are those women who there are
women who who respond by just saying
okay fine we're not going to make the
textiles anymore so we're just going to
focus on on different stuff
um but but but the point is that um if
you're
if we yeah weaving is a is a fine
example of of the kind of work which
which can which which in the in in
premodern times took place within a
productive household and and I suppose
the question I have is you know what
kinds of work let let's say you want to
be a mom and let's say you've got small
children around underf foot what's what
what's the equivalent work that's a bit
interruptible that's a bit social that's
a bit um you can pick it up and put it
down again that's not what people think
about when they think about have it all
though right it's I you can't have it
all come on everybody knows that well
they ought to like enough feminists
prior to me have have have have leveled
with the world you know you can't have
it all you know you can have a lot um
and you can you can have a great time
doing it but you can't have it all all
of the time all at once you know you
have to do some things one after another
Louise said that she she worked it out
and she was doing 40 hours a week of
breastfeeding like a full a more than
full-time job of just that part just
that one
vertical yeah underneath the child
having process yeah yeah yeah and that's
not that's not something you can can
Outsource because it's not it's not just
food you know there's there's a whole
the foundational layers of your child
mother making child making foundational
aspects of your child's capacity for
self-regulation and your child's
capacity for being being an integrated
person are laid down in those early
early interactions um it's not something
which can be subcontracted think
profoundly important this was something
that Mary eat said to me she thinks that
motherhood's a mematic desire at least
in some in some regard that um you know
one of her answers to the birth rate
decline is
that fewer mothers beget fewer mothers I
think there's some truth in that yeah
yeah I mean if you think I'm trying to
think how many how many babies did I
ever hold before my own not very many to
be honest if any it's possible it's
possible that the first baby I ever held
was my own or if not if not the first
very certainly very close to the first
and I was in my late 30s you just think
this is crazy you know there was a not
not even that long ago there was a time
when you you'd have been you'd have been
left holding younger siblings or um
other people's kids or you'd have been
around little babies and and it wouldn't
have been frightening in the same way
but it's you know the one of the reasons
you know middle middle class older
mothers like me sit and sit there you
know with our with our our our late
stage pregnancies frantically consuming
baby books is because we just don't we
don't have that we don't have that
practice around us anymore um because
families have got smaller and extended
families have got more scattered
extended families have got smaller as
well so so the the as as Mary so
eloquently explains um in her you she
writes a lot about the the shrinking of
the family and the the atomizing effect
that that that has the loss that that
imposes on Adam Lane Smith's got this
thing about how
um don't forget that moving out of the
house at 18 is a SC up by the mortgage
industry to turn one family into two
homes yeah it makes sense I mean you
could you can make the argument the same
argument for the divorce industry you
know there are there are genuinely
opinion pieces out there from divorce
lawyers arguing that divorce is good for
the GDP which it is that's interesting I
mean Mia it's kind of dark Mia Khalifa
uh very famous pawn star said
um marriage is nothing sacred this is a
recent video she put up marriage is
nothing sacred it's just a piece of
paper if the person that you're with
isn't helping you grow you need to let
them go obviously Mia Khalifa is a
paragon of successful relationship
um and I would respectfully disagree
with the sentiment and I just thought I
had this really really great guy and I'm
going to send you the episode when it
goes up this dude called mad lasson and
he tracked all of the different Western
mating ideologies over time and how they
were adaptive for the particular
cultural uh time and he goes through you
know the like agrarian the romantic and
he calls the one that we're in now the
confluent era you know I mean the the
coinage which I've used in the book is
it's not actually my coinage I forget
the the sociologists who coined it but
the self-expressive marriage which I
think is a very good and and really what
the quote the quote from Khalifa that
you just you just offered is a perfect
expression of the the self-expressive
marriage this idea that you know your
your partner is is is a vector for your
self-actualization and the moment they
stop delivering on that front you can
kick him to the curb yeah you know
there's no there's no sense of mutual
solidarity there's no sense of being in
it for the Long Haul there's no
commitment to anything which is bigger
than yourself U necessarily um except as
it except in this very transactional
sense of it it delivering goods for you
and and the M the moment that starts to
that that starts to falter or you it
goes through a rough patch for any
reason you're wholly entitled to sever
the contract and go and look for it
somewhere else it's incredibly
consumerist Paradigm but I would I I've
I argue that the the issue with that um
is that we we don't live in the age of
we no longer live in the a age of
economic abundance which which
underpinned and gave rise to that
marriage ideology it's just you know
except for except for the wealthiest who
are just Rich enough to survive divorce
and to have their children come out you
know only mildly [__] up rather than
deeply um you know for everybody else
who's further down the food chain you
know I mean divorce you know divorce and
single Parenthood is an absolute
catastrophe for a great many of the
women who go through it because it's
almost always the women who end up with
with with care of the children and I
mean the and the feminization of poverty
quote unquote is directly Downstream of
the break down of of
families yeah I mean it comes back to it
again the luxury beliefs idea Rob was
here this morning yes um and it just
Bears repeating again the best thing
that I've learned from you and you
taught me it before your book was even
out the rules that are made by the upper
classes are luxury beliefs that don't
impact them they impact the poorest
women and the poorest families and the
poorest children so it is one straight
line from
chivalry is good and you should hold the
door open for women that you don't know
as you go in and out of a hotel right
down to you shouldn't beat your wife
like it is a single straight very
slippery slope that gets slipperier the
closer that you get to the bottom yeah I
mean and if and what manifests as
holding a door open at the top of the
food chain is might if you're lucky as a
woman manifest at the bottom of the food
chain as intervening when you see a
woman being assaulted on a on a tube
platform and and the more the more you
attack the holding the door open the
less likely you are as a as a soul
traveler in late at night you know with
no with who can't afford to get a taxi
to have somebody come to your Aid if you
find yourself being attacked on a tube
platform alone yeah well and again
obviously if you've got a denial of sex
differences well why does the man need
to step in just so just so you know as
though as though the upper body strength
and the physical weight and the height
and all of those things had had all
suddenly been magically flattened by the
fact that we're talking to each other on
computer screens yeah I was talking to
Douglas about this yesterday that
gentleman who's current ly about to be
on trial in New York for choking a guy
out that was I think Dr it sounds as
though he's going to be acquitted but
that was an insane trial that was that
insane effort to Lynch somebody who was
obviously doing doing a public service
but think about how many people now in
the interim while this case is still an
open loop and maybe even after if he
gets acquitted Heary effect for any man
tempted to intervene in a public
situation like scary yeah yeah yeah I
don't want to be I don't want to be me
too or or the next Geor Floyd case or
any of that stuff exactly it's an
absolute disaster yeah it's scary what's
your thoughts on the surrogacy industry
I think it should be banned all of it
banned yeah across the board I don't
think surgy should be a thing
why little B little babies need their
mothers um and and mothers are not in no
no woman a woman is not a factory you
know gestation is not a process of
manufacturing to the for to produce a
product which can then be handed over
willy-nilly to to another another carer
um pregnancy doesn't just create a baby
pregnancy creates a mother um it
pregnancy rewies your brain it it
transforms you through a series of you
know you know you you get sort of
hormone bathed for for nine months over
the you know over the course of that
your body changes your your your breasts
change everything about you changes in
and and you it completely reorients you
towards ready to receive ready to
receive and receive baby and to
prioritize the care of baby so in in a
you're and this is this is not just true
across human species it's true across
countless animal species you're primed
for attachment and you're primed for
attent Attunement to your child um and
of course this is not to say that that
this is not to say that adoptive parents
don't do a brilliant job and there are
countless adoptive parents who wonderful
jobs and and do and care for and and
Care wonderfully for their adopted
children however um everybody everybody
accepts that a motherless child is in a
is off to a weaker start than than than
the than a child born into a loving home
where with with their mother and father
and there's a reason for that and it's
because the the ATT Attunement that that
come the that that basic biological
level of Attunement and attachment
that's primed through the process of
pregnancy um is is essential from birth
onwards to to laying the absolute
foundations of what it means to be an
integrated person um and and to say and
and I think it's just profoundly morally
wrong to say we should we should create
a a new life with the with the express
intention of severing that Bond at Birth
because somebody just for the sake of
adult desires I think that's profoundly
inverting the duty of care that we owe
to dependent infants you know we should
be prioritizing their needs not ours did
you see the episode I did with Dr animin
about life of dad and about how yes this
Al sity it's so good so she look at the
role of fathers kind of throughout all
of a child's upbringing to they leave
the home and talked about how I think
that one of her pregnancies was uh
particularly difficult and um then she
and the child had been taken away after
the birth which was successful and and
she was okay uh and the dad was just
left in there no one even came up to him
and he just thought that like Mom could
be dead daughter child could be dead uh
and no one spoke to him about it you
know all of the pre-child classes I
don't know what they're called um all of
them are focused on Mom Mom's the one
that's going to give birth it's her body
that goes through the stress etc etc but
she said fathers can deal with uh a like
post child depression what's it called
postpartum thank you postpartum
depression dads can get that um there's
this really really common issue that
fathers encounter which I saw firsthand
and then she talks about in the book
which is that uh wife is
pregnant future dad to be knows that
wife is pregnant six seven eight nine
months deep dad doesn't feel like he
cares about child dad doesn't have any
change in paternal Instinct dad doesn't
have any the bond develops after birth
for dads it develops um and there's
plenty of evidence but they feel guilt
and shame and I was sat in this I
remember where I sat in Austin with this
room like 100 millionaire 100
millionaire billionaire millionaire
millionaire 100 millionaire like big
hitters all the way around this room and
it was one of these you know guys if
anyone's got anything that they you know
they wanted a bit of advice on we've got
a room of people that are pretty capable
in here and you can say what you want
this dude was like wife's eight months
pregnant don't think I'm going to love
the kid what do I do and dude sat across
from and was like give it six months
after the birth Everything Will Change
but that fear and the guilt and the
shame and can I tell my partner does
this mean I don't love my partner does
this mean I'm going to be a terrible
father you know all of these things like
that one Insight from from that episode
I haven't had so many tags and messages
from guys in a really long time cuz I
thought I thought I was broken I thought
I was defective or I am going through
this right now my wife is X months
pregnant or the child is 3 months old
and I'm like I just feel nothing for
this kid and and and it just takes
longer for men okay so now bringing it
back to surrogacy so now imagine that um
instead of instead of it being the dad
who takes who takes that long to develop
the bond with the child now it's both
parents because neither parents has been
through the biological priming process
of pregnancy wow um now and now imagine
now let's we I can't prove that this is
going to do this is going to impact on
the on the life of a newborn baby but I
would bet you any money that it will and
I think it's just profoundly wrong to
take that immediate immediate love of of
of motherhood away from to intentionally
deprive a child of that in the name of
adult desire I just think that's
profoundly morally wrong and we
shouldn't be allowing it I think I saw a
video I was told about a video of one of
the Kardashians that one of the k iians
who was very open about this and she you
know she she procured a child by
surrogacy um and procured yeah it's it's
human trafficking Chris it's human
trafficking just using your own genetics
yeah it's human trafficking using using
sometimes your own genetics so she Pro
she procured a baby via cacy and was
very open about the fact that she really
struggled to bond with with the baby and
I was thinking you know so so okay like
we can all we can all empathize with you
maybe but like can we can we just think
about what the baby's going through here
this is a newborn baby who needs to be
surrounded by love and and responded to
with care and you know nursed whenever
it need picked up and held whenever he
or she needs it and and and both parents
are struggling to bond and both parents
are are feeling nothing and both parents
there enough nannies around to you know
just pick it up give it to the nanny The
Nanny will continue to pick yeah and I I
just I inside reading that I just wept
for the baby who was still not being
centered in the story even even as
Kardashian was talking about how she was
how about her emotional Journey even
then the child was not being centered in
the story and I I just think it's
profoundly profoundly upside down we owe
a duty of care to to the most dependent
of all and the most vulnerable which is
our babies and and every time we
prioritize our own desires over those of
our babies we're failing in that duty of
care what do you mean by Matt Walsh ISM
what's that tell me about Matt Walsh
ISM this this my I mean I don't I don't
normally I don't normally pick named
fights with with people and but when I
when I talk about Matt wal ISM this is
this is a frustration I have sometimes
with the with certain elements on the on
on the right the sort of antifeminist
right if you like you know and this this
this really comes down to where where my
arguments come from which is about you
material conditions and feminism
emerging out of the the technological
Transformations first of the industrial
era and later of the cyborg era um and
my my argument that really we have to we
have to look at where we are in terms of
the the material and the technological
conditions which are producing the these
these challenges that we now face and
sometimes I I find find myself
frustrated with those elements on the
right who seem to think that everything
about Modern Life can stay the same
except what women do and then everything
will be fine give me an example so so
for example you know it's let me let me
think of an
example that everything everything
that's wrong in the dating culture would
be wrong if would be fixed if women
would just stop being [__] to take I
mean that's a very crude example but
it's a senent that I hear you know women
just need to stop being [__] and
everything would be fine and I'm like
well okay but you know you does that
mean you're going to stop shagging
around does that mean you're going to
stop having contraceptive sex with with
random women does that mean you're going
to stop watching porn does that mean I
mean so many I mean some somebody yeah
so so so many of these quote unquote tra
men have semi-public porn habits you
know completely indiscriminate about
liking like you sort of ethought
accounts on on Instagram you know whilst
simultaneous ly ining against against
Trad women you know displaying more than
a few square inches of skin on the
internet and I'm thinking you will you
look at yourselves for a minute you know
I mean if we're going to have Chastity
can we have [__] Chastity across the
board you know I'm I'm all for more
Chastity but let's all let's all be in
in the party please you know if and if
it really is just about everything
staying the same except what women do
then yeah to to me it's the right-wing
equivalent of thumb sucking it's just
failing to look at any of the deeper
structural drivers of some of the
difficulties that we face and just just
retreating back into oh it's all oh it's
just the fault of those nasty women and
sometimes sometimes it is the fault of
those nasty women but not always and
it's never just us yeah that's
interesting and to think about um that
you got some rule of thumb about how
every political movement when it becomes
mainstream is reduced to its most idiot
possible idiotic possible version yes
the most imbecilic possible version of
it well is guaranteed to be the one that
goes Main stream well it's just the the
path of leas resistance of memes right
yeah yeah yeah yeah the more the more
reductive something becomes the more
yeah thetive it becomes I again I had a
conversation for two hours today about
memes you know and the number of times
that we quoted meme first explain later
like the stickiness arms race of a lot
of this stuff uh causes people to be
able to get ineffectual ideas across
with good branding and good advertising
and good Market
and I think that uh definitely a lot of
the stuff that's coming out with regards
to mating and dating advice is a lot of
the time that it's things that on the
surface
sounds triggers all manner of different
biases whether it be uh your sort of
tribalism against the other party the
other sex um whether it's the path of
least resistance that you're looking for
like there's a whole host of different
reasons why people end up arising at
arriving at the particular conclusion
that they do but the more it gets boiled
down to a set of just doctrinal talking
points the more useless it becomes I
mean I don't really want to get into
Insel discourse because it's not it's
actually not a Terrain I'm massively
familiar with but every so often I hear
these talking points which have trotted
out pretty much kind of without without
any context or without any sense of
qualification um you like like the one
about you know
a 10 20% of the men are getting 80% of
the women stop saying I haven't said
that for I haven't said that for two
years no no no I'm not I'm not saying
you I'm not saying
but people Trot it out as though it's
just as though it's just gospel truth
and I look around or like you know women
women won't date somebody who's less
than six feet tall and I'm like hello do
you have eyes do you ever go
outside you know this this is the
terminally online issue right and again
both of us are and this isn't me
lambasting the people that are
terminally online it's me saying that if
you are kind of the same way online yeah
but the way that the sniper tries to
adjust okay so the wind is blowing 15
knots east to west okay so I adjust how
I perceive what the target is like if
you spend this much time online so
Louise has this theory about yourself
right that I'll give you which is that
you've got a barbell strategy which is
like extremism online and extremism
touching grass and like never the twain
sh Meek and and the gray area is where
you go to die right this dark playground
where you kind of like uh I think her
husband calls it good screen bad screen
it's like I've spent enough time on
screen today which is work and Emil so I
get some good screen time tonight which
is watching Netflix or whatever but
ultimately you're still within the
confines of the game and I you know said
this a ton of times the most egregious
stories online are the ones that
garnered the most attention and people
who don't ever spend any time not being
online use those as an indication of
what the real world is like but they
forget that those stories are selected
for precisely because they're insane the
man leaves the house comes back and the
wife slept with the postman and and the
postman's dog and now he's you know left
to die under a bridge with diabetic foot
and gluten intolerance or something like
that's that story is insane which is why
it GS so much opinion and Al so much
attention and you don't know if it's
true and even if it is true it's
probably unrepresentative here's a case
a fine example of that from actually not
the dating discourse but just to just to
illustrate the point yeah there was a
video that did the rounds the other day
somebody compiled some zumas wearing
ridiculous clothes and made a little
video compilation of zumas wearing
absurd outfits and put it out on the
internet saying you know my the the
zumas are Beyond redemption or some some
caption like that you probably saw the
video like and they look stupid sure I
mean I looked stupid when I was 19 as
well I wore ridiculous clothes and and I
was I looked at this and I thought and
and I and then later I watched this
video and then later that day I drove I
drove through Cambridge which is
extremely full of young people like it's
it's very very Zuma dense environment
Cambridge um because I I had to go there
for some something or other um and I was
I was looking looking along the streets
I was thinking this is this you know 20
something you know early 18y old 19y old
20-y old W after one after another walks
past me wearing just normal
clothes I was looking at them thinking
no you're you're not soral beond
Redemption you're just wearing normal
clothes where's the cat ears exactly
where's the cat ears and the Absurd kind
of you know non-binary get up and the
and the S techn dream and the the the
18in platforms and what whatever the
hell else in this stupid video and I was
think no no literally somebody's just
gone and compiled the most extreme and
egregious um stupid stupid clothing that
some 18-year-olds were wearing and and
have tried to generalize that to
everybody and that's that's just what
the internet does as you say and and but
when you apply that to the relationship
discourse um then you end up in a
situation where people are gen it's
especially people who are not making
much of an effort for whatever reason to
reality test this against what's
actually happening out there you know
are really struggling and are finding
themselves sort of circling the drain a
bit with with in terms of their
assumptions and expectations one of my
friends referred to it as uh Shadow
Boxing in imaginary
hedgemon Fu beautiful right that you
have this thing that doesn't exist that
you're somehow compensating for and
interacting with despite the fact again
it isn't there and it
exists like in this ineffable place that
everyone kind of perceives and no one
ever sees except for in this sort of
virtual world which then impacts the way
that you show up and then you get you
know culture and counterculture occurs
to okay well [__] it like I'm going to
become a furry or whatever because I've
seen it on the internet and I know that
it pisses off the rightwing or I'm going
to become a gun toting Maga Republican
because I know that it pisses off the
you know all the way down so yeah it's
um I I give thanks every day for the
fact that I have to show up at the same
time every afternoon on the to for the
school run pickup queue why I mean if
it's not physically touching grass but
it it does it does that socially
touching grass you know I I spend I
spend all day like you know bluetoothed
into the rage machine and then I go and
pick up my daughter from school and I'm
like
yes and breathe out you know none of
none of it is real everyone in M&S you
know Twitter is not Twitter actually is
real life but it's also not real life
and it's it's important to remind
yourself of the ways in which it's not
true I think there should be for every
one hour that you spend on the internet
you should have to spend 60 seconds in
the George at Asda clothing department
like just to be like he's the [__]
normal people again you you say that I
was really interested you know to notice
in Sainsbury's as in George as in marks
and Spencer that that that Maxi
longsleeved maxi dresses have been all
the AG for some time now okay and I've
been I mean I don't know I don't know if
I is that one of the Four Horsemen of
the satorial Apocalypse I don't know
this is the thing but I i' I've been
noticing it and I'm thinking are we
going to have a is this just a sign of
economic downturn um is it just that you
know because this this is well
documented the hemlines go up when they
when when the when as the economy grows
and is it just a fact is it just the
fact that the women that women are
sensing sensing the the the coming
economic crisis I don't know or or is it
or is it the sexual counter Revolution
or is it Nei is it actually just a
fashion I don't know certainly know that
I've really noticed the trend
self-objectification from women is
correlated with wealth INE equality in
the local ecology so that's an
interesting one women seem to
self-objectify and and and sexually
objectify themselves so it was Blake's
study on the posting of sexy selfies um
and her justification for it in terms of
a mechanism was that um it shows women
not only how high they could climb but
how far they could fall with a partner
and when you see those two things side
by side it's run away from a life you
don't want and run toward a life that
you do um and that causes just something
comes online and it's like I will
Wrangle myself a husband like activate
breasts and uh you do that through the
sort of selfies that you to and it was
some insane volume like millions of
posts that they looked at to find these
correlations on the internet and yeah
that that wealth in equality so I I
definitely don't disagree that you know
especially female Behavior but also male
Behavior too can be impacted by local
ecology especially wealth inequality GDP
I mean we saw even no one ever really
spoke about this I was waiting for a
study to come out and someone may still
do it I thought that casual sex was
going to drop after covid due to a
pathogen fear from women right women
have got a much uh lower threshold for
disgust sensitivity quite rightly
because they're more uh at risk of of
bearing some sort of Burden uh and given
that we had just talk of disease and and
and infection and virus and so on and so
forth for a very long time I thought
that we were going to find a big after
effect of that I just turns out that all
of the then three-year-olds now
six-year-olds are like can't read and
have absolutely zero social skills
they've had a mask over the face for the
last three
years well speaking as a mother of a
seven-year-old that's actually not
observed that's not the case amongst my
daughter's cohort you you'll be pleased
to know that's good they all seem
actually to be fairly normal and well
adjusted kids the reading age uh or the
the reading levels for sure I think
across the um if you look at some of the
studies that have been done don't B
particularly well it seems what what
what is Def what is absolutely clear is
that there's a there's a stark economic
divide um there's there's and the the
further down the the food chain you are
economically the harder the harder hit
your children were um you know for for
understandable reason you know whether
or not whether it's because you had
limited Social Capital to or were were
struggling or were in a chaotic family
or or or simply had to had to work um
irrespective of lockdown and there your
kids are home and there's just nobody to
watch them um for for for a thousand and
one different reasons um it's been
absolutely disastrous for for for for
poorer children um to to a degree which
I think is unforgivable and shouldn't be
forgiven yeah what are you most obsessed
by as subcultures go or what are you
going to be focused on over the next
couple of months is there anything
that's that's particularly caught your
eye actually what I'm I'm I'm reviewing
I'm reviewing a a leftist sociological
academic text at the moment which is
kind of awful it's called the women of
the far right um and I'm I'm very
interested in it as a text written by
written by the left about the right but
I'm also interested in the
I me it documents it's a sort of it's a
kind of progressive sociological study
of some alt-right female vloggers from
the late from the late from sort of 2016
to 2019 including Lauren Southern and
it's kind of badly written and it's kind
of it's It's kind of dated but it's also
it's also interesting as a as a
phenomenon so I'm kind of but really
this is just a preamble so one of the
things I'm interested in and thinking
about and really sort of grappling with
is the ambivalent position of Women
Within the larger conservative or
right-wing dissident movement because it
is ambivalent because there are there
are a great many rightwing rightwing men
out there who really are violently
misogynistic you know and who genuinely
just think women are not people um and
yet um there are a great many women out
there who look at who look at the sort
of the the emerging kind of doctrinaire
Orthodoxy of the kind of the kind of the
Mad left if you you know what I mean by
The Mad left um and who just say this is
not for me and so there's a great many
women who are kind of between those two
poles and who are genuinely quite
politically homeless and I it's a it's
something I think about a lot you know I
don't really have any firm conclusions
or strong Reflections on that um except
to say this is a real this is a real
phenomenon and I don't know and it's
like I don't know I mean the it sort of
fits into a larger kind of reflection I
suppose on on digital cultures and where
we are in the discourse because it feels
as though a great many of the trends
which sort of erupted in the sort of
2015 2016 you know with kind of you know
the Trump ageddon and all the rest of it
have kind of run their course now you
know a lot of a lot of those sort of
quote unquote dissident subcultures have
now pretty much percolated into the
mainstream you know there's a whole new
set of Talking Heads who are now pretty
I mean even bronze AG pervert has been
doxed and is now you know he's now on
his foodie Arc which is just hilarious
would you so so so like where do we go
from here because all it seems like all
all that's left in the subculture is
just this increasingly unhinged
discourse about dating and I just I mean
I'm 44 and I've been married for 10
years so like I've got nothing to add to
that so like I mean maybe I should just
hang up my boots and go and do something
else and I mean I make maybe I'll start
a bakery or maybe maybe you and Bron
Bronze Age pervert can start the Bronze
Age B Bakery yeah I don't know I think
one of the reasons why Everyone is
always so interested
in talking about the dating world is
that it permits everybody to have an
opinion both those who participate and
those who do not like if you don't know
how
[__] the NFL league goes like what
have you got to tell me about how Travis
Kelce should like change his like QB
game or something like that it doesn't
matter whereas for dating people do
people do have an idea of that and
because I remember when I was working in
nlife one of my jobs was to do I'm okay
at copywriting so I would write the copy
for a lot of the social media posts my
business partner would do a lot more of
the accounts and kind of back office
stuff no one went up to him looked over
his shoulder and gave him [__] about the
way that his spreadsheets looked but
everyone has a social media account so
everyone's a [__] expert so everybody
had some oh mate I wouldn't have posted
that at that time well would that's not
the hashtag that I would have used I
thought I would definitely think that
you could have done it this way I'm like
all right well like like if you're going
to scrutinize me scrutinize the
[__] yeah exactly and it just it
never happened and I think that you know
there's a few things that people all
it's why diet is such a a breeding
ground for people to argue because
everyone's got to eat right everybody
has an idea about how and it's death
denialism as well like no my I'm going
to live longer than you my veganism is
going to beat your carnivorism and blah
blah blah and ultimately it just [__]
comes down to people wanting to be able
to espouse their opinions whilst being
insulated from the Imp one sort of one
optimistic read we could put on that
might be that you know if if we're all
still still fixated on the relations
between men and women um that I think
that that's that's a testament of sorts
to the fact that the the war on
relationships is not going to is never
going to Triumph completely you know men
and women do still want to be together
and they're going to try and continue to
trash out this even even if even if
they're kind of you know mud wrestling
horribly at the moment you know at least
on the internet I I and and again you
know Twitter is not real life even
though it kind of is real life and I I
just have to trust that somewhere
somewhere out of this messed up
discourse [__] useful and also that
there are lots of perfectly nice and
well adjusted young young men and women
who are finding one another and and
forming nice relationships that just
that just don't go anywhere near Twitter
you know when I I just have to assume
that that's also true one of the most
like sanity reinforcing periods of my
year is when I go home for Christmas and
I'm at Mom and Dad's house and the the
gruff comes on right and I watch the
gruff and I think who's this made for
this is made for families that are sat
together around the fire whether you be
shopping at waitrose or shopping at
little like that's what it's built for
and it works across the board great
story I know it pretty much by heart I
think grff grff is a solid story or you
know like the boy the mole The Fox and
the horse right like just stuff like
that and it always makes me maybe it's
just because Christmas is
a kind of wistful Whimsical time of year
that makes everyone happy but um that
always that's like my medor equivalent
of touching grass I think that's one of
the most grass-like uh watching
experiences so what is this built to
when gender right it's like just very
calming very what's that one with the
dragon what's that one with the Dragon Z
yes thank you always Rhymes um which
must be a nightmare to script but um
yeah all of those things and I'm like I
35-year-old childless man watches
children's TV this is another warning
side this is smiling at todders on a
walk isn't it um but yeah I happily
watched that and it gives me that's the
stuff that my post content Clarity of
that is like ah like everything's a bit
everything's all right I think I think I
I honestly do think we're going to be
all right you know I I sincerely believe
that it doesn't matter how hard we try
and demolish our nature it will always
find a way back I I genuinely believe
that even if even if as Louise sometimes
worries you know our culture is so
structurally anti-natalist that we're
just going to end up self selecting
against ourselves to the point that we
just render ourselves extinct um but but
that it doesn't follow from that that
all humans are going to go extinct it'll
just be the ones from this culture
effect yeah and so so Some Humans
somewhere Will Survive and it'll be the
ones who figured out how to unplug from
the Skinner machine and go back to
having kids um and but but we we like
one way or another like the that subset
of the culture which survives will be
the one that figures out how to how to
get past this kind of messed up point
that we're in but but some part of it
will survive you know I think we're
going to be all right that's the white
pill that I want to finish on Mary
Harrington ladies and gentlemen where
should people go they want to keep up to
date with all the things that you're
doing and what can they expect off you
over the next few mons I write regularly
at unheard um my my substack is
reactionary feminist um you can find me
on Twitter at moving circles hell yeah
thank you Mary thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
with Mary you will love my fulllength
conversation with Louise Perry go
on give it a press